loire qu'il y ait égalité des revenus
par exemple c'est quelque chose qui me
paraît totalement contestable d'autant
plus comme je vous ai déjà dit que les
revenus sont variables de tout au tout
au long de la vie donc c'est une une
raison aussi de ne pas pratiquer une
politique comme celle là alors on vient
de parler de du fait que le revenu
universel vauvy base permettrait de
remplacer la diversité des transferts
par un transfert unique
c'est la raison pour laquelle milton
friedman le célèbre économiste libéral
et semblait être préférable elle
semblait être d'accord avec le revenu
universel et meurent on dit souvent même
les libéraux sont d'accord pour revenir
universel mais ils étaient 80 redman
était simplement favorables à cette idée
est de permettre aux individus d'avoir
la liberté de choisir leur activité en
ayant un revenu donner et non pas une
série de revenus liés par exemple au
logement etc
donc je crois que c'est à tort que l'on
quitte les libéraux sont favorables
revenu universel
il me semble que si on est favorable à
la liberté individuelle
on ne peut absolument pas le défendre le
revenu universel
[Musique]